heute man gast im dialog friedrich merz
der vorsitzende der einflussreichen
atlantik brücke und ehemalige
cdu-spitzenpolitiker ich begrüße sie gut
unterwegs
herr merz man kann ihn ja eigentlich nur
gratulieren in diesen tagen wozu sie
haben vor sieben jahren das politische
amt das sie begleitet haben aufgegeben
wir haben jetzt extrem unruhigen extrem
unübersichtlichen zeiten da ist es doch
eigentlich ganz angenehm keine
verantwortung tragen zu müssen also zu
der kategorie menschen gehöre ich nicht
ich gebe allerdings zu ich konnte nicht
ahnen als ich 2009 aus dem parlament
ausgeschieden bin dass die jahre 215 16
wahrscheinlich auch 17 und darüber
hinaus so turbulent werden und so
herausfordernd ich hätte mich der
verantwortung auch weiter gestellt
meine entscheidung 2009 hatte andere
gründe welche waren das muss ich jetzt
ist ja hinlänglich bekannt dass es da
schon eine reihe von
meinungsverschiedenheiten auch zwischen
meiner partei ihrer vorsitzenden mir
gegeben hat im übrigen war es so ich bin
zu diesem zeitpunkt 20 jahre
abgeordneter gewesen und ich habe immer
gesagt ich will irgendwann mal wieder in
meinem beruf zurück und das war dann
nach 20 jahren auch der richtige
zeitpunkt aber die 20 jahre waren für
mich spannend interessant auch
verantwortungsvoll und ich bin
verantwortung auch nie aus dem weg
gegangen
nun sind die wie gedacht eine reihe von
jahren schon nicht mehr dabei nicht mehr
also raus aus der aktiven politik aber
immer wieder wird ja über ihre rückkehr
in die politik spekuliert wann sind sie
das letzte mal gefragt worden ob sie ein
amt übernehmen wollen also ja es wird
spekuliert aber sind eben wirklich nur
spekulationen
vielleicht auch manche wünsche und
befürchtungen zugleich ich habe mich
entschieden 2009 und die entscheidung
steht aber sind ja ein durch und durch
politischer mensch auch ihre biografie
steht ja dafür kann man denn in diesen
sehr turbulenten zeiten wie das alles
von der galerie beobachten gibt es da
nicht doch manchmal zu sagen da würde
ich gerne eingreifen oder das könnte ich
eigentlich besser machen naja natürlich
wenn man ein politisch denkender mensch
ist so wie ich schon wobei ich bin ja
nach wie vor am leben und nehme auch das
ein oder andere amt war was durchaus
politisch ist sie haben es angesprochen
mit der band brücke dass es eine der
ältesten wenn ich die älteste deutsche
amerikanische gesellschaft die wir haben
wir sind im ständigen dialog mit unseren
amerikanischen partnern aber auch im
ständigen dialog mit deutschen
gesprächspartnern nicht nur intern
sondern auch mit gesprächspartnern die
eingeladen werden von uns wir tun da
sehr viel und ich habe immer gesagt man
kann verantwortung in unserer
gesellschaft übernehmen auch ohne gleich
hauptamtlich in der politik zu sein
ich mache das jetzt mittlerweile seit
sieben jahren mit großer freude ich
werde es auch noch einige jahre machen
aber das bedeutet nicht dass man nicht
daneben auch in seinem beruf für
versuchen kann erfolg zu haben
das lässt sich durchaus miteinander
verbinden politik
gesellschaftspolitisches engagement in
diesem land darf sich und kann sich
nicht nur auf die hauptamtlichen
politiker beschränken und begrenzen
das sehe ich übrigens als eines unserer
ganz großen probleme an dass wir die
politiker da unten in der arena ständig
beobachten ständig kritisieren
und ein immer kleiner werdender teil der
bevölkerung sich überhaupt bereit
erklärt gesellschaftspolitisches
engagement und zu übernehmen ich
versuche dass beides miteinander zu
verbinden das heißt sie geben doch wenn
sie gefragt werden auch den einen oder
anderen rat in der tat wobei ich immer
wert darauf lege dass das möglichst
nicht gleich in der öffentlichkeit
stattfindet das darf sich auch nicht mit
irgendwelchen spekulationen
verbinden daran bin ich nicht
interessiert um das klar und deutlich zu
sagen
mir geht es darum dass wir in der sache
voran kommen dass wir die themen richtig
sehen und beurteilen dass wir
verschiedene meinungen austauschen
miteinander und in diesem sinne nehme
ich auch an einem politischen diskurs
natürlicher teil selten so wie heute
abend hier in der öffentlichkeit die
öffentlichkeit gehört den hauptamtlichen
politikern und denjenigen die auch die
mandate dazu haben sich zu äußern aber
gesellschaftspolitische engagement kann
auch
außerhalb der öffentlichen wahrnehmung
stattfinden man ist ja der befund der
vermutlich unstrittig ist dass wir
tatsächlich in sehr sehr unruhigen sehr
unübersichtlichen zeiten leben gerade
politisch wenn sie als engagierter
beobachter die szenerie betrachten
welche fehler sind denn da gemacht
worden ich will das gar nicht eine
zuordnung zur person sondern
grundsätzlich ich denke wir haben alle
unterschätzt und ich sage wir weil ich
eben auch 20 jahre politische
verantwortung hauptamtlich getragen habe
wir haben alle unterschätzt wie weit der
abstand zwischen der politischen klasse
und großen teilen der bevölkerung
geworden ist und zwar in fast allen
westlichen demokratien die lage ist ja
nicht nur in deutschland und in
großbritannien und in europa insgesamt
schwierig blicken sie in amerika was wir
derzeit erleben ist ja von ähnlichen
phänomenen getragen wie das was wir auch
in europa erleben die politische klasse
muss wissen dass die beobachtung und die
einschätzung der lage durch die
bevölkerung immer kritischer geworden
ist und darauf muss man reagieren
ich bin nun der letzte der ihr
ratschläge öffentlich zu erteilen hat
aber ich ziehe für mich selber auch die
konsequenz daraus wir müssen sehr sehr
viel mehr erklären jeder an seinem platz
vor steht im beruf in der politik in
jedem bereich erklären wie komplex und
kompliziert die welt geworden ist
wolfgang schäuble hat es einmal vor ein
paar tagen so gesagt das ist der ist es
deutsche von daewoo mit der
globalisierung und zwar in allen seinen
facetten nicht nur schöne offene märkte
geldverdienen gute unternehmen führen
auch der terrorismus ist ein teil der
globalisierung und diese herausforderung
die müssen wir als gesellschaft annehmen
aber wir müssen eben auch sehr viel mehr
erklären dazu das bisher getan haben es
ist nicht alles selbstverständlich die
politik erklärt sich auch nicht aus sich
selbst heraus
nun ist ja möglicherweise ein sprengsatz
für das politische gefüge in europa
die euro rettungspolitik also der
versuch eben den euro als währung stark
und stabil zu halten
wie hilfreich war es denn da eigentlich
das dann von der kanzlerin der
vielzitierte satz gefallen ist dass
diese rettungspolitik deutscher prägung
eigentlich alternativlos ist
demokratie lebt ja eigentlich von
alternativen also wenn eine demokratie
keine alternativen wer bietet ist sie
eigentlich als system am ende
na ja und wir haben ja mittlerweile eine
parteigründung in deutschland die
vermutlich mit diesem namen gar nicht
stattgefunden hätte wenn es dieses wort
vorher nicht gegeben hätte nun liegen
die ursachen für die probleme die wir im
augenblick im euroraum haben ja viel
weiter zurück ich will ehrlich sagen ich
bin 19 94 in den deutschen bundestag
gekommen zu einem zeitpunkt wo die
vorbereitungsarbeiten an der
währungsunion weit vorangeschritten
waren
ich bin dann im finanzausschuss gewesen
ich bin maßgeblich mitbeteiligt gewesen
auch an der einführung des euro in
deutschland hätte ich damals gewusst wie
sich die dinge
20 jahre später entwickeln ich hätte die
zustimmung zum euro damals wir drei und
vier und fünf mal mehr überlegt ich
hätte wahrscheinlich nicht zugestimmt
ich weiß dass zum beispiel länder der
freistaat sachsen hat damals genau aus
diesen gründen
damals war biedenkopf ministerpräsident
milbradt finanzminister der freistaat
sachsen hat im bundesrat die
währungsunion abgelegt
mit genau den befürchtungen die wir
damals nicht hinreichend ernst genommen
haben
ich auch nicht die dann leider alle
eingetreten sind
ja ist jetzt rettungspolitik
alternativlos ja oder nein sie ist es
natürlich nicht
man kann sich immer über alternativen
unterhalten die frage ist nur welche die
stabilisierende wirkung hätte es wenn
man diese rettung jetzt einstellt ich
will es klar sagen ich wäre das risiko
eingegangen
ich bin auch der meinung unverändert
dass es richtig gewesen wäre
vor gut einem jahr den griechen weitere
hilfen nicht zu gewähren weil dies wird
ein fass ohne boden
es wird vor allem ein name sie auch in
zukunft gerät
nachahmer finden wir erleben ja auch
jetzt schon dass die regeln nicht
eingehalten werden auch von frankreich
nicht von spanien nicht von portugal
nicht die eu-kommission zögert den
sanktionsmechanismus auszulösen
dabei müssen wir deutschen allerdings
auch sehr selbstkritisch sagen es waren
ja nicht zuerst die spanier oder die
griechen oder die italiener die den
vertrag gebrochen haben es waren wir die
deutschen im jahr 2002 mit den franzosen
zusammen deswegen sind wir an dieser
stelle auch schlechte lehrmeister aber
bei der konstruktionsfehler dann die art
von verträgen die geschlossen worden ist
oder die mangelnde bereitschaft diese
verträge die geschlossen worden sind ein
verhalten aus der rückschau ist man
immer klüger
trotzdem muss man glaube ich schon jetzt
heute aus dieser perspektive einmal
selbstkritisch sagen was hat eigentlich
funktioniert und was hat nicht
funktioniert
ich sehe zwei große problemkreise das
eine ist die vertrags- und rechtstreue
wir sind in europa eine
rechtsgemeinschaft und zu einer
rechtsgemeinschaft gehört dass die
institutionen und die mitgliedstaaten
sich an diese rechtsordnung halten
das tun wir seit jahren nicht das zweite
ist wir sind auch ökonomisch von
offensichtlich falschen voraussetzungen
ausgegangen ich hätte nie geglaubt dass
dieser starke diese starke absenkung der
zinsen die er mit dem eintritt in die
währungsunion für alle südeuropäischen
länder verbunden war es vergessen ja die
meisten heute wir hatten vor der
währungsunion zweistellige zinsen
kapitalmarktzinsen sowohl für die
staatsverschuldung als auch für die
private verschuldung das ist ja alles
massiv nach unten gegangen
durch die währungsunion ich hätte nie
geglaubt dass diese niedrigen zinsen von
diesen ländern genutzt worden sind für
massive ausweitung ihrer verschuldung
diese niedrigen zinsen waren ein anreiz
noch höher in die verschuldung zu gehen
ich habe immer geglaubt wer keine
abwertungen mehr machen kann sorgt für
wettbewerbsfähigkeit über
wettbewerbsfähige unternehmen über
begrenzung der kosten über begrenzung
der sozialsysteme
das hat nicht stattgefunden das
gegenteil ist eingetreten und das macht
die schwierigkeiten heute aus ich sehe
im augenblick wirklich keinen
erkennbaren weg wie man aus diesem
wirklichen dilemma aus diesem konflikt
der europa teilt und nicht ein wieder
heraus ihre prognose für den euro ist
dann zumindest was
den kreis derjenigen länder angeht die
ihn tragen
es ist sehr sehr skeptisch ob es uns
gelingt die voraussetzungen zu schaffen
um den euro auf dauer zu halten
die voraussetzungen sind heute das will
ich klar und deutlich sagen aus meiner
sicht nicht gegeben
ob wir sie hinbekommen ob die
europäischen staats und regierungschefs
die finanzminister mechanismen
entwickeln diese euro-zone so zu
stabilisieren dass sie selbst sich
selbst wieder trägt und die bedingungen
schafft um eine einheitliche währung auf
dauer zu halten
bin ich sehr sehr skeptisch in zehn
jahren ist noch dabei wäre das kann ich
nicht sagen ich weiß nur dass es so wie
es jetzt versucht wird zusammenzuhalten
nicht gelingen kann es sei denn es gibt
einige wenige staaten und dazu würde
deutschland auch zählen zwangsläufig
zählen müssen
die bereit sind hohe transferleistungen
auf dauer zu leisten um diese
währungsunion in ihrer wirtschaftlichen
disparität auf dauer zusammen zu halten
und das erklären sie mal den deutschen
wählerinnen und wählern dass dies
sozusagen der preis für europa ist ich
bin großer anhänger der europäischen
einigung nicht komme aus dem
europaparlament und das hat mich tief
geprägt sehr beeindruckt zwar eine für
mich sehr sehr lehrreiche zeit und ich
bleibe bei der festen überzeugung dass
es wirklich zu europa keine bessere
alternative gibt aber die währungsunion
spaltet europa und einsicht das heißt
das erste große opfer der populisten
überall in der eurozone ist dann europa
und der europäische gedanke
naja jetzt wird eben alles infrage
gestellt durch diese von ihnen so
genannten populisten und das ist ja das
gefährliche an der gegenwärtigen
situation populisten sind in der regel
auch große vereinfacher sie kommen ja
auch nur mit einfachen botschaften an
das können sie großbritannien
exemplarisch sehen
mit zum teil oder zum großen teil ja
sogar falschen nachrichten und
botschaften
der preis dafür ist verdammt hoch
zunächst nur für die briten aber am ende
des tages für ganz europa die politik
darf es nicht den populisten überlassen
nicht der straße überlassen die themen
zu setzen das muss die politik selber
leisten und zwar besser leisten hat sie
das bisher tut dann haben wir in
deutschland einen blick auf die
verhältnisse wo wir sagen na ja unsere
art irgendwie den auf den euro zu gucken
und mit ihm umzugehen ist eigentlich der
richtige
der blick der anderen ist falsch das
wird naturgemäß dann bei anderen ländern
anders gesehen welchen anteil hat denn
deutschland auch mit seiner euro
rettungspolitik an diesem
erosionsprozess den wir im augenblick in
europa erleben und das ist einmal daran
anders halten können in der rückschau
das ist eine mehr als nur berechtigte
frage in deutschland und das muss das
mantra der deutschen politik jeden tag
und jeden abend sein
deutschland darf sich nie wieder in
europa isolieren und ich sehe im
augenblick tatsächlich die gefahr dass
wir zunehmend in eine solche isolation
hineingeraten allerdings nicht in erster
linie wegen der euro politik oder wegen
unserer überzeugung was sozusagen die
voraussetzungen für eine stabile
währungsunion sind wir haben eine ganze
reihe alleingänge in der deutschen
politik erlebt in den letzten jahren der
die energiepolitik ist über die köpfe
der anderen europäischen länder hinweg
gemacht worden
die flüchtlingspolitik zum großen teil
über die köpfe anderer länder hinweg
dass verstärkt an diesen effekt der aus
der euro-debatte herauskommt was ich
sehr bedauere den in der euro-währung
politik in der wirtschaftspolitik
dahinter steht finde ich können wir auf
der ganzen strecke doch beweisen dass
das was wir für richtig halten auch zu
den richtigen und gewünschten
ergebnissen führt ich will es auf einen
nenner bringen niedrige schulden sind
niedrige arbeitslosigkeit raten hohe
schulden ist hohe arbeitslosigkeit das
können sie in ganz europa sehen
ich verstehe ehrlich gesagt nicht wie es
jetzt immer noch neue initiativen
ist wieder die nationale gericht also
weil franzosen italiener
das können sie auch außerhalb der europa
währungsunion sehen überall dort wo die
schulden nach wie das essen liefern
mittelbar warum ist ja warum ist das
nicht vermittelbar wahrscheinlich weil
die versprechungen jetzt mal kurzfristig
geld auszugeben kurzfristig
erleichterung zu verschaffen
auf anstrengungen zu verzichten
disziplin zu üben auch in öffentlichen
haushalten natürlich unbequem ist
bequemer ist es zu sagen auch sich als
politiker hinzustellen und zu sagen also
wir machen jetzt mal in den geldbeutel
auf und es wird für alle einfacher und
leichter und wir machen halt jetzt mal
bei niedrigen zinsen ein paar höhere
schulden dass die irgendwann
zurückgezahlt werden müssen dass
irgendwann mal die zinsen wieder höher
sind das verschweigen alle diejenigen
die jetzt kurzfristige lösungen
versprechen wir müssten mehr werben für
das was wir an auch ein erfolg über
jahrzehnte erzielt haben mit unserem
wirtschaftsmodell und letztendlich auch
mit unserer außer es ist ja das was
wolfgang schäuble offensichtlicher
unvermindert versuchte und dem er
versucht hat aber es scheint nicht zu
verfangen also zunächst einmal in der
deutschen öffentlichkeit gibt es dafür
finde ich eine sehr sehr große
unterstützung die die große zahl der
politischen beobachter und auch die
große zahl der wähler vollzieht das doch
nach und sanya die deutsche politik da
der deutsche bundesfinanzminister recht
dass das in anderen ländern der
europäischen union nicht so gesehen wird
und nicht geteilt wird ist ein teil des
problems wir haben in europa keinen
konsens in den wirtschaftspolitischen
fragen in den arbeitsmarktpolitischen
fragen letzten die auch in den
haushaltspolitischen fragen diesen
konsens herbeizuführen ist schwierig wir
haben das bei der einführung des euro
grosszügig übersehen haben geglaubt es
geben die fakten genug druck her um das
dann auch zu einer gemeinsamen lösung
werden zu lassen
aus der rückschau ist nur sagen wir uns
gehört man hat man ja die von vertrauen
ausgesprochen
das nötig ist das ja regierende immer
brauchen das vertrauen der regierten
nun ist ja eine variante vertrauen
wiederzugewinnen das einführen von
plebiszitären elementen also mehr
direkte demokratie also das befragen der
bevölkerung und ein bisschen auch ein
abrücken von der repräsentativen
demokratie kann das irgendwie einen
heilsweg sein
ich persönlich bin vollkommen anderer
meinung
das ist im grunde genommen der
offenbarungseid der repräsentativen
demokratie wenn sich annimmt
repräsentative demokratie die
verantwortung nicht wahr ja das ist
delegieren können zwar gibt es in
großbritannien sozusagen wie im lehrbuch
sehen
da sind zwei leute die das volk in eine
solche abstimmung hinein getrieben haben
und als das ergebnis dann so ist wie sie
es angeblich wollten verlassen beide das
schiff und überlassen das anderen die
verantwortung dafür zu übernehmen
ich finde das ist eher das ist sozusagen
das ist schon fast im lehrbuch das
musterbeispiel dafür wie plebiszitäre
elemente in einer rechtsordnung in einer
verfassungsordnung könnte es auch zu
einem gesinnungswandel in großbritannien
führen dass mannschaft auf irgendeine
art und weise versucht man von diesem
abstimmungsergebnis und den konsequenzen
abzurücken und einen anderen weg zu
teilen also in berlin zu bleiben mir
wird ja schon reichen wenn es in
deutschland dazu einem entsprechenden
meinungsbildungsprozess führen würde
in welche abgründe solche
volksabstimmungen führen könnten ein die
repräsentative demokratie heißt
verantwortung in der hand der gewählten
abgeordneten und wenn abgeordnete dafür
plädieren wichtige abstimmungen in die
hand der bevölkerung zurückzugeben dann
plädieren sie im grunde genommen für
ihre eigene entmachtung und feiern für
die für dich für das abgeben der
verantwortung
abgeordneter zu sein und ich war 20
jahre haben es mit großer freude gewesen
abgeordneter zu sein heißt gewählt zu
werden und verantwortung zu übernehmen
und zwar nicht nur für eine entscheidung
sondern für viele entscheidungen und
dafür am ende einer bestimmten zeit dann
auch sich wieder der verantwortung vor
den wählern zu stellen alles andere sind
in manche sachverhalte auch zu komplex
als dass man sie auf eine jahren ein
frage ist so eine parlamentsdemokratie
schafft ausgleich schafft kompromisse
eine reine plebiszitäre demokratie kann
immer nur digital zwischen 1 und 0
zwischen ja oder nein
unterscheiden schwarz und weiß aber die
welt ist nicht schwarz und weiß die welt
ist der raum untersucht eben weil sie so
wollen ja auch kompromisse zu
ermöglichen die auch für beide seiten
zugeständnisse erfordern das können sie
naturgemäß in solchen volksabstimmungen
niacin im gegenteil sie verschärfen noch
die konflikte in einer gesellschaft auch
das können sie jetzt exemplarisch in
großbritannien sind wenn es zum exit
kommt oder kommen sollte dann müssten ja
möglicherweise auch die verträge die
maastricht verträge noch mal
überarbeitet werden die europäischen
verträge
bisher war es ja so daten vor kurzem
noch mal der ifo-präsident sinn der
ehemaligen ifo präsident sinn darauf
hingewiesen bei uns im programm
das jahr mit deutschland und
großbritannien eine sperrminorität da
war es verschieben sich die
machtverhältnisse in richtung
schuldenländer in richtung
südeuropäische länder auch was natürlich
dann unserer form von währungspolitik
und von umgang mit währung mit dem euro
dann zuwiderlaufen würde
müsste man die verträge dann sich
nochmal entsprechend vornehmen um das
aus zu justieren
zunächst einmal sind die briten nicht in
der währungsunion und deswegen betrifft
es unmittelbar jedenfalls die
währungsstrategen maastricht vertrag
nicht richtig ist dass deutschland mit
großbritannien wenn denn der ausdruck
tatsächlich kommt einen wichtigen
partner verliert der immer wieder auch
in den europäischen ministerräten dafür
gesorgt hat dass bestimmte vorstellungen
ebendort nicht durchgesetzt werden
konnten
deutschland wird ein sommer in europa
keine frage ohne großbritannien und
vertragsänderungen erfordern die
zustimmung aller mitgliedstaaten
erfordern
die parlamentszustimmung in allen
mitgliedstaaten und sie erfordern in
einigen mitgliedsstaaten
volksabstimmungen
also ich sehe es überhaupt hier das in
den nächsten jahren überhaupt an eine
vertragsänderung zu denken ist da bin
ich völlig wenn man eine büchse der
pandora
ja da bin ich völlig war wolfgang schott
und angela merkel die das beides sehr
deutlich gesagt haben wir müssen jetzt
die probleme lösen und nicht unter über
vertragsänderungen reden
die probleme werden groß genug das heißt
auch vorschläge wie sie jetzt gemacht
worden sind unter anderem vom parlament
präsidenten des europäischen parlaments
schulz über eine vertiefung nachzudenken
in richtung auch einer größeren
verlagerung von kompetenzen auf europa
weg von den nationalstaaten hielten sie
nicht für ratsam mir schien dass ein
gewisser schnellschuss zu sein aus der
situation des augenblicks heraus um
keine sozusagen schockstarre in europa
auch in deutschland entstehen zu lassen
nach diesem foto der briten realistisch
ist es nicht denn wir werden jetzt
zunächst einmal von tag zu tag von woche
zu woche von monat zu monat die probleme
lösen müssen die es in europa gibt und
da wird keine vertragsänderungen ergeben
das sehe ich überhaupt nicht in den
nächsten jahren sie sind position der
atlantik brücke das heißt sie versuchen
den dialog zwischen deutschland und den
vereinigten staaten zu intensivieren
sie werben gegenseitig für verständnis
jetzt haben wir sie haben es eben auch
schon kurz angesprochen auch in den
vereinigten staaten
verhältnisse wie man sie sich so erst
mal nicht denken können wir haben es
möglicherweise zu tun mit einem
präsidentschaftskandidaten der
republikaner der donald trump heißt
können sie uns dieses phänomen donald
trump erklären hier aus deutscher sicht
betrachtet schaut man da ja immer etwas
verwundert drauf ja auch da aus der
rückschau ja vielleicht hätte ich vor
allem jahr bei ihnen gesessen hätte ich
es für vollkommen ausgeschlossen
gehalten dass ein mann wie donald trump
präsidentschaftskandidat der
republikaner wird
ich hätte mich grob getäuscht er hat 16
zum teil sehr ernsthafter und erfahrene
mitbewerber aus dem feld geschlagen
und heute muss ich ihnen sagen ja es
kann sein dass dieser mann präsident der
vereinigten staaten von amerika wird
woran liegt das
auch in amerika gibt es eine krise der
institutionen diejenigen die möglichst
weit weg sind von washington genießen
große popularität diejenigen die
washington sozusagen als die die quelle
allen übels der amerikanischen
gesellschaft bezeichnen bekommen große
zustimmung hillary clinton ist teil des
washingtoner establishment gar nicht
negativ gemeint aber das macht ihr
schwierigkeiten in der eigenen partei
und wir haben es insgesamt mit den
beiden unbeliebtesten
präsidentschaftskandidaten zu tun die es
jemals in amerika in zeiten normal der
der modernen wahlforschung gegeben hat
auch hier eine große entfremdung
zwischen politischer führung und der
bevölkerung
das heißt es auch ein stück eliten
versagen was ich da und zeigen es ist
eine wir sehen eine klare politische
institutionen eine tiefe vertrauenskrise
letztendlich auch der demokratischen
mechanismen aber auch der
ausgleichsmechanismen der alte
amerikanische traum vom tellerwäscher du
kannst von ganz unten nach ganz oben
kommen stimmt eben nicht mehr
die mittelschicht ist sozusagen
eingekeilt zwischen hohen steuern und
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen und wenig
durchlässigkeit nach
da brodelt in dieser gesellschaft etwas
was eben dem amerikanischen traum und
der amerikanischen perspektive nicht
mehr entspricht
aber dann habe ich doch in europa wie in
den usa eben diese krise also der eliten
die möglicherweise auch auf falsches
verhalten ich jetzt nicht wieder
versagen aber die auf falschem verhalten
beruht wie lässt sich das denn
zurückgewinnen wenn man gleichzeitig
sagt also man will schon dass die
bevölkerung auch ein differenziertes
bild bekommt und sich entsprechend auch
bei wahlgängen verhält also abwägt und
nicht mehr sozusagen emotional aus dem
bauch heraus auf platte parolen fliegt
die politik muss jederzeit in der lage
sein zumindest den eindruck zu
vermitteln nicht mit fassaden sondern
mit substanz dass sie probleme ernsthaft
angeht und lösen will
und als eines der großen probleme in den
westlichen bevölkerung wird angesehen
die immer ungleicher werdende verteilung
von chancen und auch von vermögen
wenn man die statistiken sieht ist die
ungleichgewicht ich kite längst nicht so
groß wie sie behauptet wird aber sie
wird als solche empfunden und politik
ist eben auch ein teil des umgangs mit
empfindungen also muss man bei der
vermögensverteilung etwas verändern oder
muss man nur erklären das ist eigentlich
nicht so schlimm ist wie teilweise
ersetzen
ich glaube beides ist richtig aber es
müssen auch wieder die chancen erkennbar
werden und es müssen diese exzesse
aufhören zwei und dreistellige millionen
gehälter in den usa und in europa die
amerikaner sind da etwas großzügiger
oder etwas weniger von neid erfüllt als
wir es vielleicht auf dieser seite des
atlantiks häufig sind aber auch in
amerika stoßen diese wall street exzesse
mittlerweile doch auf große skepsis und
auf erheblichen protest sein man wie
bernie sanders kandidat der
demokratischen partei in der letzten
runde noch ist als einer von zweien
jemand der sich selbst als sozialist
bezeichnet das muss doch ein warnsignal
auch an die amerikanischen eliten sein
dass es so weit kommen kann dass jemand
der sozialist sein will in amerika
solche chancen bekommt unvorstellbar
noch vor wenigen jahren
also hier verändert sich im verhalten
der bevölkerung etwas und die hat sich
auch für die bevölkerung in der
perspektive etwas verändert und das wird
gefährlich für die gesellschaft auf
beiden seiten des atlantiks ist es auch
wenn man mal zurückkehrt zur nationalen
politik eine herausforderung für die
union auf diese auf dieses gefühl eine
antwort zu finden ja ich sage ihnen auch
ganz konkret in welchem bereich uns geht
es so gut wie nie zuvor im durchschnitt
und natürlich gibt immer
einzelschicksale aber uns geht es
verdammt gut aber wenn es uns in 20 30
jahren auch noch gut gehen soll dann
müssen wir ganz ganz dringend etwas
dafür tun dass die alterseinkommen
stabilisiert werden
die erwerbseinkommen sind in ordnung
jetzt lassen wir mal die exzesse die es
auch in deutschland gibt kurze zeit
außer betracht aber im grossen ganzen
sind die erwerbseinkommen in ordnung das
wirkliche problem entsteht dass weder
die gesetzliche rentenversicherung noch
die betriebliche altersversorgung noch
die private altersvorsorge ausreichend
grundlage sind für ein gesichertes
einkommen im alter
und dafür müssen wir dringend etwas tun
die kapitalbildung in privater hand in
privater arbeitnehmerhand ist notleidend
und da muss die politik ganz schnell
handeln um langfristig effekte zu
erzielen
die dieses problem einigermaßen statt
diese langfristigkeit ist ja
offensichtlich auch ein problem
sie hatten es eben angekündigt also es
wird sehr viel für den moment gemacht
ohne eben zu bedenken was hat
langfristig für folgen hat ist das etwas
was auch ihre partei begriffen hat ich
hoffe dass ich beobachte das ja mehr von
außen und von innen ich hoffe dass wir
das insgesamt verstehen und ich denke
das ist einer der gründe warum wir
zurzeit so viel unwille und unmut in der
bevölkerung haben dass es der
protestbewegungen ganz links ganz rechts
gibt die sich ja in ihrer wortwahl und
in ihren themen sehr ähnlich sind
wir müssen verstehen dass eine große ein
großer teil der bevölkerung wieder
längere perspektiven längere linien
sehen will
auch für die eigenen kinder und
enkelkinder sehen will wie geht es den
denn in 20 und 30 jahren in deutschland
und nicht immer nur kurzfristig von der
hand in den mund leben dürfen und
entscheiden können herr merz bedanke
mich für das gespräch